Prof: Our subject this
morning,
and next time,
is the AIDS pandemic,
and I'll start this morning
dealing--
in a sense by popular demand,
because I know from visiting
sections that people were
particularly concerned with
bringing this study up to date
and talking about where we are
at the moment.
So, I'll be concentrating
largely on the global pandemic
and where we are today.
Then next time we'll look more
conventionally at the history of
the AIDS epidemic,
focusing on this country and
the experience of the United
States--
is how I'm proposing to do it.
We'll start with the sort of
run through of things that you
probably know very well,
but that we really ought to
discuss a bit as background--
the nature of the disease,
its course in the body and its
symptoms--
and then we'll move on to the
epidemiology of where the
pandemic is today,
and some of both the worrying
aspects about this pandemic,
and also a couple of the rays
of hope,
that of progress that has been
made,
especially in the last couple
of years.
So, that's where we're headed
this morning.
First of all,
in terms of the disease--you
know already,
because we've talked about
viruses--in this case a
retrovirus.
Here we have a slide,
a schematic picture of the HIV
virus.
You know about it;
that it's a core containing two
strands of genetic material,
RNA, encased in a membrane,
with two glycoproteins on the
surface.
The glycoproteins,
particularly this one,
120, is crucial for allowing
the virus to target certain
cells.
In the case of this virus,
it targets the T4 cells in the
body,
which are the ones that
regulate antibodies and are the
regulators of the body's immune
system.
Well, once attached to the T4
cell, the RNA penetrates the
host cell, and for a time it's
inactive, even for years.
There then occurs a trigger,
or detonator,
which may be--this is a little
speculative--
an infection that activates the
T4 cells,
and then the RNA is converted
into DNA that penetrates the
chromosomes of the host cell and
turns it into a factory for the
reproduction of the virus and
the killing of the cell.
So, the retrovirus is an
absolute parasite.
It takes over the controls of
living T cells and turns them
into factories to reproduce
virus.
Now, this we can see also in a
picture.
This is a slide of an infected
T cell, and this is an image of
a cell reproducing HIV.
And finally let me show you,
this is a picture of an HIV
particle budding from an
infected T cell.
This is how the--part of the
mechanism of the disease.
And let's talk about what
happens to the body in terms of
symptoms.
First there's an incubation
period of some six to eight
weeks, after which there occurs
the primary infection.
Symptoms at that stage,
in the majority of cases,
are flu-like;
that is to say fever,
night sweats,
muscular aches and pains,
fatigue, swollen lymph nodes,
headache, sore throat,
sometimes diarrhea,
sometimes a rash.
Then the symptoms disappear
after a few weeks,
and in many cases there's a
prolonged period that's entirely
asymptomatic.
This is a period of latency,
which can last months,
and has been known to last even
as long as ten years or more,
the time being entirely
unpredictable.
But during this period,
the virus continues to multiply
and destroy the cells of the
immune system.
Then there comes the period of
active AIDS, where there are
direct lesions caused by the
retrovirus, carried in some
cases to the brain.
Sometimes there's neurological
damage, known as AIDS dementia,
or loss of motor control,
memory, sometimes reasoning
power.
But the characteristic,
as you know,
of AIDS, different from most
infections,
is that it's not the symptoms
that it causes itself,
but rather its ability to give
rise to opportunistic infections
by switching off the body's
immune system,
making it vulnerable to an
exotic variety of infections
that the body is unable to
fight.
This is immunosuppression.
Later in the disease,
the victim experiences weight
loss, lethargy,
recurrent yeast infections,
rashes or sores,
fevers and night sweats.
Active AIDS develops when a
patient has fewer,
with HIV, than 200 T cells per
micro liter of blood.
The normal count is 800 to 1200.
From this point,
the average untreated--and I
stress untreated--AIDS patient
has about two or three years to
live.
Sometimes other symptoms
develop: difficulty swallowing,
loss of memory,
cough, shortness of breath,
sometimes seizure,
nausea or impaired vision.
But death is usually caused by
a whole array of opportunistic
infections,
with names familiar to you,
like candidiasis,
pneumocystis carinii
pneumonia,
Kaposi's sarcoma,
cytomegalovirus,
cryptococcal meningitis;
but above all tuberculosis,
which is the most important of
the opportunistic infections of
AIDS,
and globally,
at least, the most common
immediate cause of death.
Note this characteristic of
AIDS.
Its course is not just the
direct result of the virus
itself on the body,
but those pathologies which are
substratum are combined with
those of a series of other
diseases superimposed on the
AIDS virus,
because of the progressive
destruction of the immune
system.
And note how well adapted the
virus is to its ecological niche
in the human population.
It's a lethal disease,
but one that avoids killing its
host too quickly.
A major evolutionary advantage
begins with a lengthy
asymptomatic latent period,
as HIV, when it's contagious,
but the infective patient
almost certainly doesn't know
that he or she harbors the virus
in his or her body.
And then full-blown AIDS can
last for long years,
while again the patient remains
infective.
Well, what about transmission?
Transmission can occur in a
variety of ways.
As you know,
it's transmitted sexually.
Everyone knows that.
We need to remember there was a
myth about AIDS,
in the outset in this country
in the '80s, that it was a gay
plague, that it spread
homosexually.
And you all know about the
Moral Majority and Reverend
Jerry Falwell,
who welcomed AIDS as God's
sword to destroy homosexuality.
Apart from blasphemy,
and the arrogance of a claim to
know God's will,
what's most striking about
Falwell's comment is his
complete ignorance of the facts
of epidemiology.
The virus is present in bodily
fluids: blood,
semen, vaginal secretions,
breast milk.
So, one means is certainly
sexual intercourse;
especially intercourse
involving an infected partner
where there are lesions that
allow the virus to penetrate the
skin and enter the bloodstream.
Hence sex, heterosexual or
homosexual,
where there's a pre-existing
venereal infection such as
herpes,
is particularly dangerous,
or sex that causes abrasions,
such as anal intercourse.
The risk factor is not
homosexuality but promiscuity,
by which I would define as sex
outside the context of a loving
relationship,
whether heterosexual or
homosexual.
In Africa today,
it has been established
epidemiologically that multiple
partner sex behaviors account
for two-thirds of all new
infections.
But AIDS can be transmitted in
other ways, despite what Jerry
Falwell said.
It can be transmitted through
the blood by shared needles and
syringes, for example,
needles that haven't been
sterilized but are shared.
One thinks of injecting drug
users.
One can think also of patients
in resource poor health systems,
in which needles are scarce and
not routinely sterilized.
One can think also of unsafe
blood supplies;
blood that isn't screened,
and is supplied to people by
people who are remunerated,
thereby making every
transfusion a risk for HIV
transmission,
for patients who have surgery,
or for hemophiliacs.
Another factor,
of course, is the sex industry,
where the disease spreads
rampantly among sex workers and
their clients.
And then there's vertical
transmission,
a real shock to Jerry Falwell.
The disease can be transmitted
transplacentally from mother to
fetus, or from mother to infant
via breast milk.
This is one of the drivers of
the present day pandemic.
In 2008, the latest statistics,
children constituted just under
twenty percent of all new
infections,
and nearly the same percentage
of AIDS-related mortality.
Well what about the
epidemiology of this pandemic?
We're now a quarter of a
century into the global AIDS
epidemic.
And I would argue that AIDS is
a good example of one of the
themes with which we began our
course: whether epidemic
diseases are part of the big
picture of history.
I would argue that you wouldn't
be able,
in the future,
to write the history of the
late-twentieth and twenty-first
centuries without devoting an
ample space to the AIDS pandemic
and its consequences.
From the standpoint of the
industrial world--
Western Europe,
North America--some people have
a comforting illusion that the
emergency has been controlled;
for a couple of reasons.
One is the fact that the number
of cases in the developed world
has leveled off;
except that in the last few
years there have been some
troubling signs,
including right here in the
United States.
And secondly,
there's been the development of
expensive drug cocktails that
have reduced mortality
significantly,
with many patients experiencing
the disease as a chronic
illness.
But we need to be very careful
about complacency.
There are only seven countries
in the world that have more
cases of HIV infection than the
United States.
In 2006, there were 1.2 million
people living with HIV in the
United States,
and the number is not declining
at all.
Furthermore,
we need to remember that living
with HIV as a chronic disease is
itself enormously problematic.
It means an expensive and
complicated regimen of pills,
and the medication itself is
toxic and has unpleasant
side-effects.
The evidence seems to suggest
too that patients with HIV-AIDS,
under treatment,
experience nevertheless a
significantly higher incidence
of other diseases,
and that they die at a
significantly lower age.
And then very disturbingly,
since 2004 there's been a real
spike in HIV infections among
men who have sex with men.
Meanwhile, worldwide the
pandemic continues.
In the words of the UNAIDS
Report for 2008,
it was continuing at a
staggering level.
At the end of 2007,
the World Health Organization
reported globally that 33
million people were affected by
HIV/AIDS;
that there were 4.5 million new
infections during that year,
and during that dreadful year
nearly 3 million AIDS deaths.
That's something like 8,200
people a day.
2006 also witnessed 4.3 million
new infections.
In 2007 and '08,
the number of deaths decreased,
and that was partly due to the
increased access to therapy,
antiretroviral therapy,
that lowered mortality.
In 2010, for the first time,
UNAIDS suggested some reasons
for optimism,
but optimism of a strictly
limited kind.
Not that progress was being
made to controlling and
decreasing the epidemic,
but that it seemed to have
leveled off.
That was one of the hopeful
stories of the UN Report of this
year.
It remains true though that
most people in resource-poor
countries who need retroviral
therapy still don't receive it.
But let's look at some of the
graphs.
This was HIV at the end of
2005, and it shows the total of
40.3 million people with
HIV/AIDS,
and below that it shows the
numbers of newly infected people
and the number of AIDS deaths
for 2005.
And this gives you some idea of
the dramatic inequality of the
burden of HIV/AIDS,
that it's enormously a burden
in Sub-Saharan Africa,
which has more than half of the
total number of AIDS people in
the world.
Or let's look at this picture,
which just gives a clear
indication of where the
epicenter of the AIDS is,
which is in Southern Africa;
countries such as Botswana,
Lesotho, Swaziland,
Namibia, South Africa,
Zimbabwe, Angola,
Mozambique.
There the WHO reported in 2006,
and again in 2008,
that the epidemic was still
rampant, that the trend still
offers no comfort.
And in the sub-region as a
whole, life expectancy has
actually declined,
because of AIDS,
to below fifty;
plunging to levels not seen
indeed since the 1950s.
Swaziland and Botswana have the
unhappy distinction of having
the world's highest prevalence
of HIV/AIDS.
And here you see the worst-case
scenario.
Twenty-six percent of people
are infected with HIV,
the highest levels ever
recorded, as are twenty percent
of pregnant women.
Those are rates of prevalence
that the Center for Disease
Control once thought to be
impossible,
and life expectancy at birth
dropped below forty years in
several countries in the region.
With nearly 6 million people
living with HIV,
in 2008, South Africa has the
sad record of possessing the
largest HIV epidemic in the
world in absolute numbers,
not though per capita.
Now, epidemiologically it now
seems that there are two great
divergent patterns in this
terrible epidemic.
In the industrial world,
it's primarily an affliction of
high-risk groups.
We'll talk about them in a
moment: men who have sex with
men;
sex workers;
injecting drug users.
This is what the World Health
Organization calls
"concentrated
epidemics,"
in which the pandemic is
confined,
above overwhelmingly,
to certain high-risk groups.
But there's a second and more
devastating pattern,
clearly evident in southern
Africa,
where HIV/AIDS is a leading
cause of death,
and where transmission among
high-risk groups certainly
occurs,
but it's overwhelmed by
transmission in the general
population.
There transmission is primarily
through heterosexual sex,
and significantly more women
are infected than men.
And it's also true,
as I've said,
that transmission occurs on a
large scale,
vertically from mother to
unborn child,
so that significant numbers of
children are born with
congenital AIDS.
Why women?
And this is again one of the
themes of our course,
and I'll be dealing in part
here with poverty,
and not just poverty but
inequality.
Women, in part,
because of biology.
The disease is more easily
transmitted from men to women
than vice-versa.
It's also true,
clearly true in Sub-Saharan
Africa, that sexual activity
tends to start earlier for
women.
Young women in many parts of
Sub-Saharan Africa also
frequently have sex with much
older partners.
Sexual inequality also fuels
the sex industry,
as does--the epidemic is primed
also by violence against women,
and often the inability of
women in many situations to
negotiate safe sex practices.
In many parts of the world
girls are simply severely
discriminated against in terms
of education,
and therefore do not acquire
sex education and knowledge
necessary to take effective
measures to protect themselves
and control their reproduction.
Girls who have not received
primary school education are
twice as likely to be infected
with HIV as those with higher
educational attainments.
And as I said,
violence against women is a
major factor in the epidemic.
It's also true that we need to
mention cultural norms in these
areas where notions of
masculinity are important
determinants of male behavior
patterns that increase the risk
of AIDS;
the idea that it's meritorious
to have multiple partners,
and unmanly to use condoms.
Well, this is an epidemic that
can serve also as a review for
some of the themes of our
course.
We see this epidemic being
primed by a number of factors
that by now are familiar to you,
in comparative discourse.
There's a clear link with
poverty.
The countries with uncontrolled
epidemics are among the poorest
nations in the world,
and poverty is directly linked
with the epidemiology of
HIV/AIDS.
Poverty prevents national
governments from building
effective public health
structures, or educational
infrastructures.
And studies of sectors most at
risk from the epidemic in
southern Africa--
that is, sexually active young
people in the fifteen to
twenty-five age group--
those studies reveal that large
numbers of people of that age
group still do not have an
accurate understanding of the
mechanisms of AIDS transmission.
Local studies also show in some
places the disturbingly large
numbers of sexually active young
people--
twenty-five percent have been
discovered in places--
still have no idea of what a
condom is.
Poverty prevents people from
having access to means to defend
themselves: education,
medical care and treatment for
those already infected.
It drives recruitment into the
sex industry,
another major driver of the
pandemic.
It leads to unemployment,
demoralization and alienation;
all of which fuel high-risk
behavior, including intravenous
drug use, and that in turn leads
to further unsafe sex practices.
Then there's the social and
economic impact,
which is maximized by the age
profile of the victims
themselves;
that is, young men and women in
the prime of life,
who should be the mainstays of
families and their economies.
In some places poverty even
destroys the effects of sex
education itself.
In Uganda, for example,
the newspaper the Uganda
Monitor,
reported two years ago that
condoms remained so far beyond
the means of many people that a
widespread practice was to boil
them after use and reuse them.
Then another theme in our
course.
We've talked about urbanization
and its role with certain
diseases;
not all, malaria was clearly
very different.
But it's no coincidence that
southern Africa,
where the pandemic is rampant,
is also rapidly,
rapidly urbanizing,
and that indeed twenty percent
of the global burden of HIV/AIDS
falls on fifteen cities in
southern Africa.
Another theme of our course is
represented by AIDS,
and that's the impact of
conflict and war.
The movement of troops once
again has proved to be ideal for
sexually transmitted diseases,
and for prostitution.
And the spread of other
STDs--syphilis,
gonorrhea and herpes--actually
furthers the spread of AIDS.
The lesions that they cause,
like genital ulcers,
provide ideal portals for entry
of HIV into the body.
Trade and modern means of
transport have been important.
One can't understand the AIDS
epidemic without roads,
railroads, the airplane.
Societal neglect is a theme
we've talked about,
and national governments,
in some cases nations that are
poor and under-developed and
have virtual status as almost
failed states,
have been incapable of taking
major initiatives on their own,
in terms of improving the
health of their populations.
But in some cases they also
have other priorities.
There's the siren song of
military spending.
There's corruption.
Or let's take the case of the
former president of South
Africa,
Mbeki, who refused to take
science seriously,
and rejected the idea that the
HIV virus causes AIDS.
He called on people not to use
condoms, but simply to drink a
mixture of olive oil and garlic
as a prophylactic of choice.
So, there's been a current of
AIDS dissidents who reject the
link between the virus and the
disease.
Fortunately,
that situation has changed.
Then there's stigmatization,
which is a cause of the spread
of the epidemic.
It causes people at risk not to
seek medical attention,
and that in turn undermines
surveillance and active
understanding of the
epidemiology of the disease.
And the inequality of women who
are stigmatized has a number of
structural consequences:
that is,
in terms of inheritance laws
that disenfranchise them;
unequal jobs in the economy;
violence;
early sexual debut;
and large-spread practices of
what UNAIDS calls
"transactional sex."
In Kenya, for example,
teenage girls are three times
more likely to be infected with
HIV than boys of the same age,
and the differential,
instead of decreasing,
increases with age.
There's also the displacement
of people, and HIV/AIDS thrives
on migrant labor,
on disrupted families,
on refugee status.
And in industries where
migrants live,
for example,
among miners,
in compounds at vast distances
from their homes and families,
a situation that leads to the
thriving of commercial sex.
Mobile populations are at high
risk of infection.
And then one of the vicious
factors of HIV/AIDS is the
burden of the disease itself,
which causes the burden of
poverty to increase,
and poverty furthers the
epidemic.
AIDS then leads to a vicious
downward spiral in which poverty
creates favorable conditions for
AIDS.
AIDS breeds poverty, and so on.
In the words of the UNAIDS
Report for 2008:
"HIV causes a greater loss
of productivity than any other
disease,
and is likely to push an
additional 6 million households
into poverty by 2015.
HIV has inflicted the single
greatest reversal in human
development in modern
history."
That was the UN Report.
And then there is
super-infection;
that is, multiple infections
with different strains of AIDS.
And one of the most tragic
factors of all is the phenomenon
of AIDS orphans.
The WHO reports staggering
numbers of them.
It terms it "a crisis of
gargantuan proportions."
Already in Sub-Saharan Africa,
11 million children under
fifteen are orphans;
a number that's expected,
given current and projected
prevalence of HIV infection,
to reach the staggering figure
of 25 million in a few years.
In the worst infected cases,
it could be,
if this actually materializes,
that one child in five could be
an AIDS orphan.
What are the effects of this
dreadful pandemic on societies?
Again we see that this
functions almost as a review of
themes of our course.
Clearly no one would be able to
write the history of the present
moment in southern Africa
without giving a central place
to HIV/AIDS.
HIV/AIDS prevents education and
literacy.
At the heart of the epidemic in
Botswana is the fact that the
disease kills teachers more
rapidly than they can be
replaced;
that poor families,
with a member ill from AIDS,
can't afford to send children
to school.
The fact that it destroys
healthcare systems.
In many countries in southern
Africa fifty percent of all
hospitalizations are due to
HIV/AIDS,
and nearly all other healthcare
interventions and programs have
therefore been erased or
radically downscaled.
It destroys productivity and
creates a crippling burden of
disease,
destroys families and
communities, thereby trapping
whole countries in
underdevelopment and
international dependency.
It destroys civil society and
undermines democracy.
It's the substratum for a
lethal epidemic that follows in
its wake,
the reemergence of
tuberculosis,
the classic opportunistic
infection complicating HIV/AIDS.
And TB is rising at a rate of
six percent per annum in
southern Africa,
where 2 million cases of TB are
diagnosed a year.
Businesses find that they're
crippled.
There are high rates of
absenteeism.
There's a real shortage of
skilled workers available.
There are high rates of
turnover, and it's extremely
expensive to train new workers.
And, of course,
the rocketing healthcare
expenses that they face.
There's a major cultural impact
on societies.
Clearly this undermines any
confident sense that a society
is protecting one.
There's a demographic impact.
We've already seen the way in
which HIV/AIDS is altering the
age structure of whole
populations and transforming
life expectancy.
And there's even the
possibility of failed states as
a direct result of disease,
with enormous implications for
security,
political stability and
democracy.
But this last fact
paradoxically has also opened a
ray of hope.
The realization that I last
mentioned affected the national
security estimate of our own
government,
which reckoned that in fact
HIV/AIDS was a major threat to
the security of the United
States;
the first time that disease was
recognized by the CIA and the
security community as a threat
to our country.
And this was reinforced by
studies by, for example,
the RAND Corporation.
The result of this realization,
that we are indeed a global
community,
and that what's happening in
Southern Africa and other places
is of enormous impact throughout
the world,
led to a massive investment of
funds.
And I'd most like to mention
PEPFAR, the President's
Emergency Plan for AIDS Relief,
that was established by
President Bush in 2004.
It now targets fifteen
countries, has been extended
under President Obama,
and those countries are
primarily, though not
exclusively,
in southern Africa.
Initially it was fifteen
billion dollars over several
years,
and has been renewed since,
and it became the largest
commitment of funding to an
international health effort ever
recorded.
This has led with the--there's
also funds through the Gates
Foundation particularly directed
at research,
and through the Global Fund for
HIV/AIDS,
Malaria and Tuberculosis.
One of the conclusions is that
there's been--
that we could reach--is that in
the last years,
under this massive new
investment of effort and
funding,
that the world health community
is developing much more
sophisticated strategies for
dealing with this epidemic,
that it has much more data and
information,
and that it's learned a number
of important,
indeed vital, lessons.
What are some of the
conclusions that provide us with
at least a measure of hope?
One of them is that in
campaigns against this disease,
one size definitely does not
fit all.
And here we see another theme
of our course,
that information,
hard data, is absolutely
crucial to any effective public
health strategy.
Public health needs to be based
on a solid basis of information,
and in this case we see a rapid
up-scaling of testing and
surveillance as one of the key
components of the global effort
to combat the disease.
That's necessary because it
establishes the clear idea that
the epidemiology of this disease
in each society is distinctive,
and that in turn enables the
campaign to concentrate
resources,
to change tactics,
depending on the actual results
of the interventions so far.
So, you need to be able to,
in order to have sound public
health,
scientifically to assess what
you've done to date,
and to change course if it's
not working properly.
One of the hopeful signs in the
AIDS pandemic is that the
campaign has become more
sophisticated and focused.
It has been realized that
strategies that fit one phase in
the history of the epidemic may
not be effective at another
stage.
And, so, the response has
continually to be updated and
adapted.
The priority now is to clearly
identify high burden areas as a
priority, and to saturate them
with prevention efforts.
The slogan of PEPFAR,
for this reason,
is "Know Your
Epidemic."
In the past,
for example,
anti-AIDS programs failed to
target married couples,
and people in long-term
relationships,
couples in which one partner in
particular is HIV-positive while
the other is not;
in the jargon of the World
Health Organization,
"discordant couples."
Another lesson,
that the commitment cannot be
short-term;
that it must be sustained.
That short-term interventions
that are then scaled back can be
useless and counter-productive.
A good illustration is Uganda,
which a few years ago was one
of the bright spots in Africa.
When the government invested
heavily in sex education,
in the provision of condoms,
and the fostering of new and
healthy sexual behaviors,
the results were highly
successful,
until funding was scaled back
in favor of other priorities.
And since then,
the epidemic in Uganda has
resurged with a vengeance.
And one could say something
similar about Thailand.
There are also new strategies.
Let me give you a couple of
examples.
One is the need to abolish the
distinction, in this pandemic,
between prevention and
treatment as a false dichotomy.
Because treatment with
antiretroviral therapy is in
fact a valid and essential
preventive strategy.
In particular,
antiretroviral therapy
radically lowers the incidence
of vertical transmission from
mother to child.
It's also true that
antiretroviral treatment lowers
the viral load,
and therefore reduces
transmission.
Antiretroviral therapy is a
prophylactic because it prolongs
the life of parents,
thereby decreasing the number
of orphans and vulnerable
children;
the very people who fuel the
sex industry and are most likely
to indulge in unsafe sex
practices because they lack
education,
resources and access to medical
care.
PEPFAR has concentrated
recently on making generic
antiretroviral therapies
available in focused countries,
at an affordable price,
and the FDA,
in this country,
has established fast-track
approval to allow
antiretrovirals to be rapidly
reviewed and cleared.
By the end of 2008,
antiretroviral therapy had been
extended to 10 million people
with HIV/AIDS,
and especially to pregnant
women who are HIV-positive.
Another hopeful sign.
At first, PEPFAR was
ideologically motivated,
and stipulated that one-third
of its funding had to go to
abstinence-only education.
But this has been demonstrated
by results to be
counterproductive and so has
largely been dropped,
and funding has been redirected
toward other aspects of the
program.
Another stress has been on
gender inequality.
And here I want to stress that
it's not only poverty but
inequality that drives this
epidemic forward.
Let me give you the example of
Swaziland, which is at the
epicenter of this pandemic.
One third of women in the
eighteen-to-twenty-four age
group were found to have
experienced sexual violence,
as had one quarter of girls
under fifteen.
So, providing education and
re-education,
stressing the dangers of power
differentials in intimate
relationships,
has been important in
demonstrating the devastating
consequences of sexual
entitlement,
and also offering adolescent
women vocational training so
that they would have the skills
necessary in the marketplace,
and hence the economic
independence that was a major
determinant of public health.
Until recent years,
HIV/AIDS programs avoided what
might be called socioeconomic
and cultural determinants of the
pandemic,
concentrating on generic
awareness,
but not confronting the
specifics of local situations
that fuel the epidemic.
Let me give you an example of
targeting specific high-burden
groups and areas.
One of them has been in recent
years the targeting of
intravenous drug users,
and removing ideological
blinkers, and simply talking in
terms of epidemiology and hard
science,
leading to such innovations as
needle exchange programs to make
blood safe,
and indeed in a couple of
countries to opioid substitution
treatments to remove,
or at least to downscale,
heroin addiction,
thereby once again lowering the
rates of transmission.
Another major intervention has
been on establishing safe blood
supplies,
combating what we might call
the medical transmission of
HIV/AIDS,
through the establishment of
laboratories,
when with them the screening of
all blood and the recruitment of
donors from low-risk sectors of
the population on a
non-remunerated basis.
Or there's been the awareness
of the utility of male
circumcision as a prophylactic
measure in this pandemic.
Let me then just contrast the
situation in Sub-Saharan Africa,
where the epidemic is,
in the population,
the general population,
with a couple of other worrying
places in the world--
and I'll end then on a slightly
more somber note--
some places that are currently
sources of concern,
outside of Africa.
There's Eastern Europe,
and the former areas of the
Soviet Union,
where UNAIDS has talked about
an emerging epidemic,
unlike that of Southern Africa.
The epidemic has a different
profile.
It's a concentrated epidemic,
showing prevalence among
high-risk groups,
like intravenous drug users.
In Saint Petersburg,
thirty percent of intravenous
drug users are under
nineteen-years-of-age,
and the sharing of needles is
the norm.
And it's also driven by the sex
industry,
and by the collapse of the
healthcare system,
and fueled also by some
religious attitudes which scorn
sex education and the use of
condoms,
or devote resources to a
practice of abstinence
education,
which has demonstrably not
worked.
Or there's East Asia and the
Pacific;
again, injecting drug use,
sex industry,
low condom use and sexual
tourism, all of these being risk
factors that are cumulative.
I'll conclude just with a
couple of worrying points about
our own country.
The outbreak began in the '80s,
as far as we know,
peaked around 1993,
and then declined steeply until
approximately the year 2001,
since which time there's been
an upturn;
and a surprising degree of
misinformation has abounded.
New infections,
we can see, demonstrate that
the epidemic has been
transformed,
and the epidemic in the United
States is totally unlike what's
happening in Southern Africa.
New infections are
overwhelmingly among men;
718,000 males affected and
160,000 women.
And it tends to be among
concentrated groups:
men who have sex with men;
drug users;
and ethnic
minorities--African-Americans,
who have half of the new cases
in the last few years,
and Hispanics.
A transformation occurred.
AIDS in the 1980s was primarily
a disease among the white
population.
It has since declined among
whites, and spread disturbingly
among minorities;
African-Americans,
Hispanics and Asians.
So, at that point I'll refer
you to Wednesday,
when we'll talk about the
United States in greater detail.
And I'll just conclude,
since I've run out of time,
by saying that the pandemic at
the moment is extremely active.
The most hopeful thing I could
say to you is not that it's
being controlled,
but that it seems to be
globally stabilized;
but there are a number of
really worrying places in the
world, and some very worrying
developments.